switching gears back here in clark  county prosecutors in illinois say they  would like a local hit-and-run suspect  extradited out of nevada 51-year-old  colette de spain appeared in court this  morning  she's accused of hitting and killing a  tow truck driver ryan billett  as he was working on a car on the side  of 215.  the attorney for the defendant there to  spain says illinois contacted nevada  authorities  to put an extradition hold on her our  i-team has reached out to the clark  county district attorney's office to try  and find out more information  to spain is in jail for now bail is  expected to be addressed april 13th  nevada highway patrol says de spain de  spain was on probation at the time of  the crash